not all jokes are created equal and some
come with a price tag to prove it in the
American version of the office the
pricey gag occurred during a season 3
episode entitled to Benihana Christmas
fans will no doubt remember the show's
consistent quality when it comes to
Christmas specials and for a lot of
people the Benihana episode tends to
rank among the best this holiday romp
opens with Carol Stills showing up at
Michael Scott's office to dump him just
before the holiday party while there are
many good reasons we can think of to
break up with season 3 Michael Scott the
last straw for Carol is a doctor
Christmas card created by Mr Scott in
which he spliced his own head on top of
an image of Carol's ex-husband from an
old ski trip she took with her family
what you didn't realize at the time was
that I was with you in a sense I was in
your heart and next to your kids what
this this is so weird this setback sets
up the drama of the episode Michael is
now stuck with two tickets to sandals
Jamaica and no one to enjoy the trip
with on top of that he has to show his
face at his office Christmas party
without a date office suck up Andy
Bernard decides to take the heartbroken
Michael on a boy's outing to Benihana to
help him forget about Carol which white
and Jim and Tow they head out to an
awkward and boozy Hibachi lunch that
actually results in them picking up two
young waitresses Michael and Andy bring
their new girlfriends back to the office
Christmas party and hilarity ensues
memorably Michael has to make a mark on
his girlfriend's arm with a sharpie so
he can remember which one is his
although a nice Hibachi dinner can
certainly start to add up especially if
you order too many of those onion
volcanoes it wasn't the food that pushed
the comedy bill into five figure
territory on this one while the use of
Benihana's corporate trademarks came
cheap but different intellectual
property issue required NBC to pay the
piper on a recent episode of The Office
ladies podcast a delightful bit of
weekly fan service hosted by Jenna
Fisher who played Pam and Angela
Kingsley who play Angela former staff
writer Jen Salata stopped by to spill
the beans on the expensive gag according
to Salata the joke that ultimately had
NBC reaching deep into its corporate
Pockets was a four second gag where
Michael sings a couple of bars of Two
Tickets to Paradise by any money through
relish's upcoming vacation to a Sandals
Resort in Jamaica
of God Two Tickets to Paradise
but your bags were leaving day after
tomorrow
in her appearance on the office ladies
podcast soleta said that the short joke
came with a large price tag she was
informed of this fun fact after the fact
by producer Kent zbornak at the sound
mix I found out from Kent
that that was a sixty thousand
thousand I've been the sixty thousand
dollar joke saletta wasn't sure but she
told the podcast that she recalled the
Show's music budget being reduced not
too long after the episode leading her
to believe that her little joke may have
had a way bigger impact than she'd
anticipated the process of song
clearance is a notorious pain in the
entertainment business and it can easily
wreck a show where movies production
budget is costs get out of control
what's your funding two hundred dollars
what's ours again
um 201
in order to clear a song lawyers
representing the network in this case
NBC had to work with the music label
that holds the publishing rights for a
song that's featured during an episode
no matter how small or incidental the
feature in this case Eddie money's
publisher Columbia Records made sixty
thousand dollars off of Michael's
pre-cover performance not too shabby for
four seconds worth of someone else's
work as an interesting aside a Benihana
Christmas had another issue with song
clearance one scene from the episode
features an office performance of John
Mayer's saccharin love song Your Body Is
a Wonderland office star BJ Novak who
plays Ryan the temp is actually friends
with mayor in real life and was able to
negotiate a pretty reasonable settlement
after overcoming some initial
apprehension the cost of mayor's song
One personalized Dundee award statue for
tallest music dude
[Music]
filmmaking is a tricky business it's a
long journey from the script to the
screen and the lots of great and not so
great scenes get left on The Cutting
Room floor costing the studio time and
money he has a look at some of our
favorite films whose deleted scenes came
at a high price creatively and
financially World War Z's darker final
acts World War Z didn't distribute an
expensive scene or two this movie's
entire third Act was gutted and replaced
in post-production in the theatrical
ending the movie concluded with Brad
Pitt's Jerry Lane wandering around the
research laboratory and discovering the
scientific solution to all the world
zombie problems first in the original
shoot things were supposed to be a lot
of Grimmer for our hero before the
revisions Jerry and his sidekick segan
would have made it to Russia to do a
blockbuster size battle with zombies and
discover a method of Undead defeat of
the old-fashioned way but there was
still trouble on the home front as his
wife and children were in North America
and this should turn to prostitution to
provide for her family and ultimately
shagged up with her former colleague
played by Matthew Fox this would have
culminated in Pitt's character questing
across Siberia to make way to his now
estranged wife leaving room for what
would have been a full-on Trilogy of
World War Z films but the studio wanted
a happier ending for the film and
brought in a bunch of new creatives to
rewrite and reshoot the third act and
everything else including almost all of
Fox's parts were left on The Cutting
Room floor never to see the light of day
not only did Paramount lose the money
they'd already spent for the clipped
scenes but the reshoots ended up costing
a whopping 25 million dollars as well
and that friends is what you call a
pricey pivot Rogue scenes and X-Men Days
of Future Past with its crazy time
travel plots X-Men Days of Future Past
is packed with familiar faces but
unfortunately that means limited screen
time for some of our favorite characters
including Anna paquin's Rogue the True
Blood actress spent a week filming
several elaborate scenes for the 20 2014
Blockbuster alongside fellow X-Men vets
but none of it wound up in the finished
film director Brian Singer told
Entertainment Weekly through the editing
process the sequence became extraneous
like many things in the editing process
it was an embarrassment of riches and it
was just one of the things that had to
go after fan outcry singer and 20th
Century Fox released a rogue cut of the
film on DVD restoring 17 minutes of
previously cut footage that included
Paquin sequences the original tragic
ending of Little Shop of Horus if all
had gone as director Frank Oz and a
screenwriter Howard Ashman had initially
planned this 1986 adaptation of the
Broadway musical wouldn't have ended
quite as happily the pair intended to
use the ending from the stage version of
Little Shop of Horus with Audrey 2
eating Audrey and Seymour and
terrorizing the world but test audiences
hated it does it have to be human baby
does it have to be mine ours records the
Entertainment Weekly for every musical
number there was Applause they loved it
it was fantastic until we killed our two
leads and then the theater became a
refrigerator an icebox in order to get
the movie released they needed better
audience approval so the elaborate's
23-minute sequence which cost her
aborted 5 million dollars was scrapped
and The New Ending was shot with the two
leads alive and well though a black and
white version of the original ending was
included on a 1998 DVD release full
color footage was finally included in a
director's cut edition Blu-ray in 2012.
the Jitterbug dance number from The
Wizard of Oz the wicked witch uses a lot
of different tactics to try to stop a
Dorothy and her friends in The Wizard of
Oz but one never made it into the final
version of the film in the last
Jitterbug sequence Dorothy the Scarecrow
Tin Man and Cowardly Lion travel through
the Haunted Woods only to be attacked by
evil bugs that caused them to break out
in song and dance also a popular Dan's
style at the time the Jitterbug was
actually a remnant of an older version
of the script that was tossed out the
whole number cost about eighty thousand
dollars and took five weeks to shoot but
it was cut when producers decided the
film was too long though the actual
footage was destroyed composer Harold
Allen captured a dress rehearsal of the
number on video later included at an
extra on the DVD version of the film
maybe the original footage will turn up
in a studio storage space like Dorothy's
old ruby slippers did returning to
Krypton and Superman Returns before DC
and Warner Brothers decided to reboot
the Superman franchise yet again in 2013
with Zack Snyder at the helm Brian
singers 2006 entry starring Brandon
Ralph as a man of steel flew into
theaters with fairly mixed reviews
Superman Returns also nearly arrived
with a completely different opening
sequence while the basic plot of the
film deals with Superman's return to
Herb after a five-year absence singer
shot a wordless visually stunning five
minutes opening sequence with Ralph
Superman visiting what was left of his
Home Planet Krypton the scene which cost
an estimated 10 million dollars is slow
and contemplative rather than bombastic
and exciting maybe that's why producers
ultimately had singer cut it the scene
was finally released as an extra on the
2011 Superman Anthology Blu-ray sets
further dividing critics and fans on the
one-off superhero flick Eric stalks his
scenes from Back to the Future as most
Back to the Future fans know Eric Stoltz
was originally cast as Marty McFly the
puffy vest wearing teenager sent back to
1955 in a souped-up DeLorean director
Robert samakis initially wanted to hire
Michael J fox but his family ties
shooting schedule was too demanding at
the time and he hired Stoltz instead
five weeks into filming the Marcus and
producer Steven Spielberg knew they
needed to replace Stoltz because he just
wasn't funny enough zamarcus and
Spielberg are quickly negotiated with
universal to replace Stoltz with fox
adding a reported 3 million dollars to
the film's budget and extra time onto
its shooting schedule soon Fox was on
set at the Twin Pines mall shooting with
Christopher Lloyd and the rest of course
is history
heavy
over 400 TV shows are broadcast every
year and that means the competition for
viewers is fierce as a result networks
are often willing to spend big money on
projects they think will lure in the
biggest audience they Place their bets
and sometimes lose their shirts here are
some of the most expensive TV flops to
ever have their plugs full
Battlestar Galactica most people today
know Battlestar Galactica as the
marathon worthy Sci-Fi series that ran
from 2003 to 2009 hardcore fans however
might remember that the series
originated in 1978 and tanked in the
ratings a year later setting out to be a
TV take on Star Wars the original
Galactica cost roughly 1 million dollars
per episode more than double that of a
typical Primetime show at the time and
the equivalent of over 3.7 million
dollars today at first it was worth the
price tag the series early episodes
attracted positive reviews and healthy
ratings but those ratings eventually
began to slip and behind the scenes
issues like censorship made production
difficult ultimately Battlestar
Galactica couldn't pull its weight as
compared to other less expensive Network
kits such as ABC's own Morgan mending
and the show was canceled after a single
season the network did give it another
go with Galactica 1980 but that show
only lasted 10 episodes before being
decommissioned due to non-existent
viewers
super trained when it comes to expensive
flops you'd be hard-pressed to find a
bigger train wreck than 1979's super
train as you might expect from the title
the NBC show was basically just love
boat meets snow piercer set on a massive
nuclear-powered locomotive featuring its
own nightclubs and casinos that could
speed from New York to Los Angeles at
200 miles per hour the thing is the
train didn't actually exist so the
show's creators used expensive model
trains while filming unfortunately the
models weren't particularly durable and
one of them was destroyed in a crash
before the first episode was even filmed
after the show debuted to downright
terrible ratings famous celebrities were
brought on to keep super train on track
Tony Danza Rue McClanahan and Dick Van
Dyke all made guest appearances but even
that late 70s star power couldn't stop
supertrain from going off the rails the
show was canceled after nine episodes
and remains one of NBC's costliest flops
to date at a reported 4 million dollars
an episode
father of the pride it makes a lot of
sense that after Shrek raked it in at
the box office NBC was willing to Fork
over big bucks DreamWorks for a computer
animated show of Their Own It makes a
lot less sense that they decided that
the project that would be worth 2.5
million dollars of their money would be
a show that recast the white lions from
Siegfried and Roy's famous Las Vegas
magic act as a wacky sitcom family the
result was father of the pride unlike
Shrek which somehow spawned an
Unstoppable franchise that we just can't
seem to get rid of it failed to capture
the hearts and minds of those who
watched it it did however capture plenty
of unwanted attention the parents
television Council flooded the FCC with
allegations that father of the pride was
indecent to make matters worse the show
came in hot on the heels of Roy being
nearly mall to death when one of his
Tigers dragged him off stage by the neck
the first such accident in more than 5
000 shows with all that stacked against
it it didn't take long for NBC to make
the show disappear after only 13
episodes
Viva Laughlin when some shows get
canceled they leave viewers feeling like
they missed out on something good that
never got a chance to shine when CBS
dropped the hammer on 2007's Viva
Laughlin however it was a mercy killing
that freed the audience from what the
New York Times suggested might be the
worst show in the history of television
made in an effort to diverge from the
standard lineup of police procedurals
and grandparent focused sitcoms CBS
banked big on a remake of Viva Blackpool
a popular BBC show with a bizarre
premise a murder mystery that would
occasionally break out into elaborate
musical numbers where the cast sang pop
songs
[Music]
despite the presence of producer and
star Hugh Jackman critics and viewers
alike hated the casino themed musical
from the opening number its ratings were
dismal and it quickly became a go-to
punch line on the e-network's the soup
as the show beloved by hundreds which
might have been overstating after only
two episodes Viva Laughlin danced way
off Airwaves and with the pilot
purportedly costing 6.8 million dollars
cutting losses early is probably the
right call
Camelot as the first series ordered
under Chris Albrecht the newly crowned
president and CEO of stars hopes for
riding high on 2011's Arthurian drama
Camelot according to Albrecht the show
was based on quote an idea of hope that
has resonated at different times
throughout history unfortunately 2011
was not one of those times critical
reviews of Camelot were less than
Stellar but while the show still saw
solid ratings during its final episode
Stars canceled the fantasy drama after
only one season scheduling conflicts
would lead cast members Joseph fines
Jamie Campbell Bauer and Ava Green made
a sophomore effort more trouble than it
was worth and it was worth quite a lot
according to the Wall Street Journal the
series cost roughly 7 million dollars
per episode that's a lance a lot of
money huh look you can't blame us for
trying that one
Kings betting on the star power of
deadwood's Ian McShane the riding
prowess of American Gods Michael green
and some assistance from The Hunger
Games Catching Fire director Francis
Lawrence NBC seemed poised to hit it big
with 2009's Kings an ambitious drama
reimagining the life of the biblical
King David in a modern setting the
two-hour Premiere cost a massive 10
million dollars with each subsequent
episode coming in at 4 million dollars a
pop with that kind of money behind a
television series you better believe the
stakes were hot in this case producers
rolled snake eyes and cashed out with
dismal ratings but Kings wasn't just
costly for NBC Liberty Mutual invested a
5 million dollar sponsorship into the
show reportedly aiming to subconsciously
piggyback on the show's message of
personal responsibility to encourage
viewers to buy insurance with barely
anyone watching the show however it's
safe to assume Liberty Mutual didn't
exactly get what it paid for Kings was
first banished to the dog days of summer
before NBC officially called liquids
still the show isn't as bad as its
rating Supply and it might be worth
going back if you missed it the first
time around
Marco Polo
Netflix is no stranger to dropping big
money on big projects but in the case of
2014's Marco Polo the series never
really found its way to an audience and
wound up losing big in the process at
the time of Marco Polo's release No
active series was more expensive to
produce except HBO's fantasy Juggernaut
Game of Thrones the first season of
Netflix's Kublai Khan Center drama
caused a staggering 90 million dollars
which weighs in at 9 million dollars per
episode unfortunately for Netflix Marco
Polo never came close to Game of Thrones
success despite lackluster critical
reviews Netflix gave Marco Polo a second
season the sophomore effort was less
popular than the first prompting the
streaming service to give the series the
ax in this case a 13th century mongolax
[Music]
take a staggering amount of money to
make and nowadays any budget below 50
million dollars is considered mid to low
range that level of spending usually
works at the end since movies also make
a staggering amount of money but not all
producers are lucky enough to earn back
their investment in the case of these
films the films did so poorly at the box
office that they're considered
cautionary tales in Tinseltown
The 13th Warrior adapted from a Michael
Crichton novel The 13th Warrior is
Loosely based upon the myth of Beowulf
while the film earned some recognition
for its expensive set pieces those
costly moments ended up ballooning the
film's budget to 160 million dollars
while the box office returns were only
61.7 million dollars leaving the film
with a deficit of almost 100 million
dollars the movie's failure to find an
audience is a bit of a Puzzler since the
source material was by a proven
best-selling writer and it was directed
by die hard's John mctiernan but no
matter the reason the end results were
so embarrassing that the co-star Omar
Sharif ended up briefly retiring from
acting in disgust
The Adventures of Pluto Nash Eddie
Murphy used to be a reliable hitmaker
with successes in everything from
action-adventure films to zany comedies
to movies that required him to suit up
for almost every character he even had
some successes on the family film scene
with Dr Doolittle and Shrek confirming
that kiddos like to laugh at him just as
much as adults but his star power burnt
out somewhere between those films and
The Adventures of Pluto Nash because the
film earned back just 7.1 million
dollars of its 100 million dollar budget
it's not hard to see why the film fared
so poorly with mediocre special effects
a confusing and unfunny script and a
nonsensical future setting even Eddie
Murphy's big name couldn't save the film
from flopping hard
okay
stealth Rob Cohen was behind the lens
for a number of hits including the Fast
and the Furious and triple X but his box
office streak took a serious nosedive
when his Aviation actioner stealth
crashed and burned at the box office the
film followed a crew of Air Force pilots
trying to control an artificial
intelligence jet but instead of being a
compelling Adventure movie it was more
like a science fiction parody of Top Gun
it grossed just 76 million dollars
against a 135 million dollar budget and
made good on its title by sneaking away
from the theaters largely unnoticed
Sahara based on a massively successful
series of books about a rugged
Adventurer with a quick wit and Away
with women Sahara looked like it might
be able to recapture the magic of
Indiana Jones unfortunately for everyone
involved the built-in audience for the
books didn't translate to a box office
success and Sahara grossed a modest
119.3 million dollars that wasn't enough
to cover its 160 million dollar budget
and 81 million dollars in distribution
costs part of it could have just been
poor timing since the movie starred
Matthew McConaughey before his star
power returned in full force with the
mcconissons it'd be a lot cooler if you
did you could but either way the studio
was parched after this movie's returns
Mars Needs Moms Disney's experiment with
motion capture performance co-produced
by legendary director Robert zemeckis
seems like a good idea on paper and Mars
Needs Moms wasn't conceptually Off the
Mark either as it followed a
nine-year-old trying to save his mom
from Aliens who wanted to harness her
powers to juice up their Nanny Bots
which is the stuff of Fairly standard
Family Fare but while the film's effects
were cutting edge they gave an almost
uncomfortable eeriness to every
character's facial expressions and
rather than an exciting Adventure or a
surreal nightmare of a film the movie
ended up being a snooze audiences on
Earth didn't have much interest in it
handing over just 39 million dollars in
ticket fare against a whopping 150
million dollar budget The Mouse House
might not usually have trouble wrangling
in the kiddos to see their animated
features but this movie Marked a major
breakdown for the studio speaking of
Disney flops in outer space
John Carter based on the seminal works
of Edgar Rice Burroughs which influenced
everything from Star Wars to parts of
the DC Universe John Carter seemed like
a sure thing on paper in practice though
the film felt ironically derivative and
trite John Carter managed to make 73
million dollars domestically with
worldwide sales barely pushing the film
past its 250 million dollar budget
considering it took around 100 million
dollars more to market the movie Disney
took a hefty loss on the would-be
tentpole project the title hero of the
film might be less affected by gravity
on Mars but here on Earth he was brought
down hard
RIPD the title of this film is an
acronym for the Rest in Peace Department
a special police force that takes care
of renegade Spirits before they can
affect the human world it's basically
Men In Black with the supernatural twist
and the casting of Ryan Reynolds as the
upstart partner to Jeff Bridge's grumpy
Mentor seems like a no-brainer
unfortunately the movie was pronounced
DOA barely making back 78 million of its
100 130 million dollar budget while the
failure of certain films can sometimes
be attributed to poor marketing Studio
interference or even rival movie
releases that are oddly similar the
blame for RIPD rests pretty entirely on
the film itself it's relentlessly on
funny bridges and Reynolds seem like
they're so bored with the script that
they might as well be on the other side
but hey maybe they were just method
acting the whole time
tough day
The Lone Ranger the character The Lone
Ranger is a classic part of American pop
culture unfortunately for the makers of
the 2013 reboot of the hit TV and radio
series however the film was plagued with
problems from start to finish for
starters the film Drew ire overcasting
Johnny Depp as the Native American
sidekick Tonto which prompted massive
criticism over its decision to whitewash
the character then there was the matter
of its bloated budget which was 215
million dollars before marketing costs
and to top it all off critics laughed at
the film for all the wrong reasons
Justice
maybe just pick a different hat next
time
whether emptying the streets of Times
Square racking state-of-the-art sports
cars for fun or blowing up real military
ships the movies on this list have
invested heavily in solitary scenes
lasting mere minutes these sequences are
the most expensive movie scenes ever
filmed Vanilla Sky sets the tone of
surreal reality question and confusion
from the opening scene the perfectly
groomed gray hair plucking Playboy
millionaire David Ames wakes as
radiohead's everything in its right
place aptly lyricizes his life
Immaculate Flawless perfected yet as
David drives his vintage Ferrari through
the streets of New York the first cracks
in this illusion appear he drives to
Times Square the crossroads of the world
with approximately 330 000 daily passers
by it's completely empty not even the
faintest hint of the usual hustle and
bustle David wakes abruptly it was all a
dream a false Awakening interpreted by
his therapist as a metaphor well I
suppose The Empty Street meant
loneliness
you're a shrink you gotta do better than
that at only 30 seconds of screen time
the scene provides a fundamental
function in the narrative questioning
the nature of reality and our
relationship to dreams surprisingly no
CGI was used instead director Cameron
Crowe struck a deal with the NYPD to
close off the area between 5 AM and 8
A.M on a Sunday in November 2000. the
result was a spectacular sequence with a
spectacular price tag over 1 million
dollars for 30 seconds of footage was it
worth it absolutely combining Cruz's
enigmatic star power with the desolate
backdrop helps create a poignant scene
lacking in the 1997 Spanish language
original open your eyes
in I Am Legend Will Smith roams the
post-apocalyptic streets of New York
City as Dr Robert Neville a virologist
attempting to find a cure for the
zombie-producing Crippen virus
to create the feeling of desperate
isolation the film like Vanilla Sky Has
empty streets to match Warner Brothers
empty wallets however a substantial
chunk of its 150 million dollar budget
was allocated to a much more populated
scene capturing Neville's tragic
separation from his wife and child in
flashbacks the audience sees that New
York City was evacuated and placed under
quarantine during the outbreak in a Race
Against Time Neville's family boards a
helicopter to escape then comes a
breathtaking moment of tragedy the
military bombs the Brooklyn Bridge
amidst the chaos the Blazing Bridge
collapses into the water below and
Neville's family tragically dies in The
ensuing accident
a fair share of digital magic was used
to capture the missile's impact
still the surrounding evacuation was
shot on location across six nights
requiring the cooperation of 1 000
extras 14 different government agencies
and expansive lighting rig and a crew of
250.
increased bureaucracy post 911 made
acquiring the green light on the project
a task that cost a cool five million
dollars
think of James Bond and what's the first
thing that comes to mind aside from a
cat-stroking Evil Genius cool gadgets
and Bond girls the answer is probably
luxurious cars after all what would 007
be without an Aston Martin DB5 for
company a car featured in seven
different installments snazzy
automobiles are largely part of the
series mythology and Specter continued
that tradition by placing Daniel Craig
in the front seat of the stylish Aston
Martin db10 a car produced exclusively
for the 2015 film illustrative of the
multi-millions Hollywood has to play
with 32 million dollars of specter's
rumored 300 million to 350 million
dollar budget was spent destroying cars
the biggest expenditure came from
totaling seven of the 10 aforementioned
db10s a fact that will no doubt cause
car enthusiasts to shed a tear Chief
stunt coordinator Gary Powell told the
Daily Mail in Rome we wrecked millions
of pounds worth the db10 sped through
the narrow streets of the Vatican at top
speeds of 110 miles per hour in a cat
and mouse Chase with a henchman in a
Jaguar cx-75 a set amount for this
singular scene hasn't been confirmed but
the number of destroyed db10s were quote
shot one entire night for four seconds
of film making its cost per footage
ratio astronomically High
smashing db10s to Smithereens is Frugal
when compared to Brian singer's Superman
Returns resurrecting Kyle on screen
nearly two decades after Superman 4 the
Quest for Peace one particular scene
depicted Superman returning to Krypton
abstract atmospheric and visually
striking the CGI heavy sequence is
intriguing channeling elements of
thoughtful slow paced sci-fi however
that tone was such a stark contrast to
the rest of the film a fun superhero
movie that Warner Brothers chose to cut
it out of the final cut it was a bold
decision not least from a financial
perspective creating Superman's
Homeworld cost an estimated 10 million
dollars making it one of the most
expensive scenes in history and most
likely the costliest deleted scene ever
Superman Returns earned favorable
reviews although it failed to capture
the imagination of audiences illustrated
by an underwhelming worldwide box office
of 391 million dollars maybe that
Krypton scene would have helped
four years after Neo swallowed the red
pill and unveiled the true nature of
reality in The Matrix the philosophical
cyberpunk sensation returned in 2003
with the second installment in the
trilogy this time the wachowskis had
over double the budget which it's safe
to say they spent wisely ignoring the
adage don't play with traffic the duo
rejected digital effects and instead
constructed a fake freeway at a
decommissioned naval base in Alameda
California
you always
told the way
yeah true stretching a mile and a half
the set was the backdrop for reloaded's
White Knuckle Chase between Morpheus
Trinity the Twins and a host of Agents
surprisingly the wachowskis also opted
for real-life stunts Trinity actress
Carrie Ann Moss who overcame a quote
major fear of motorcycle shooting the
scene told IGN they needed to have the
best stunt people in the world it was
dangerous you could really feel that
every day you went out there the final
result is 20 minutes of mind-blowing
physics-defying Carnage and one of the
most memorable car chases in cinematic
history as for the total cost that had
the blue pill treatment never to be
revealed publicly however the freeway
alone cost 2.5 million dollars throw in
over 100 destroyed cars practical
effects and CGI and a significant
percentage of the 150 million dollar
budget was likely spent on this single
sequence
the second world war was one of the
deadliest conflicts in history with
casualties estimated to be over 56
million one of the most bone-chilling
unfathomably brutal battles the D-Day
Landing was also the largest Seabourn
invasion in history those who weren't
there will never truly know what it was
like but Steven Spielberg's acclaimed
portrayal in 1998 Saving Private Ryan
offers some insight most notable is its
depiction of the Allies arrival on Omaha
Beach a tense sequence Empire magazine
ranked as the quote greatest battle in
cinema an unforgettable opening 25
minutes depict Tom Hanks Captain Miller
facing impossible odds marching through
blood-soaked sand outmaneuvering
explosions and dodging bullets leading
the way for the Allies eventual victory
at the German occupied Shore it's
filmmaking at its finest realistic
immersive heartbreaking and it earned
Spielberg the Oscar for best director
shot over the course of four weeks a
cast of 750 captured the horror of that
fateful day on June 6 1944. unable to
shoot at Omaha Beach Spielberg shot on
location on the east coast of Ireland At
Kira close strand with minimal Direction
in the original script most shots were
quote spur of the moment and unplanned
ahead of time Spielberg told DGA
quarterly of the approach it helped make
things a little more chaotic and
unpredictable considering the magnitude
of the scene and its lasting cultural
impact its 12 million dollar budget
might have been a good deal
Michael Bay is renowned for
larger-than-life spectacles brimming
with huge explosions and bombtastic set
pieces epitomized by his live-action
Transformers franchise clearly there's a
thirst for big robots that turn into
things with the series earning a total
worldwide box office of 4.48 billion
dollars Autobots
the last night was the most poorly
reviewed in the series receiving a
measly 15 on Rotten Tomatoes but that
wasn't due to a lack of investment its
budget was a whopping 217 million
dollars with a large chunk of that spent
on location for one particular scene as
previous Transformers installment age of
Extinction concluded in a junkyard
producers were Keen to maintain
continuity Phoenix film commissioner
Phil bradstock Riley remarked to Phoenix
Business Journal the movie's art
director was probably just doing a
Google image search for a junkyard and
they came across this junkyard just
north of Deer Valley Airport Arizona's
authorities won't be complaining about
the fortuitous Google image search
though it led to a hefty investment in
the area in a rare detailed Insight
bradstock revealed that over the 10-day
shoot producers hired 40 locals to work
behind the scenes as well as 50 local
vendors and 3 000 cumulative Hotel
Nights two months on location equated to
an investment of 15 million dollars
before factoring in CGI and other cost
increasing factors
Marlon Brando was widely regarded as one
of the finest actors of his generation
if not any generation when he won his
second Academy Award for his captivating
portrayal of Don Corleone in 1972's The
Godfather
that film was also a blockbuster and if
the producers of the first big budget
Superman movie wanted to secure the
great Brando to play Superman's father
jorel they were certainly going to have
to dig deep and pay up I'm gonna make
him an offer again reviews Brando
ultimately appears in 1978 Superman the
movie for about 10 minutes out of the
film's 143 minute running time and yet
he received top billing over both
Academy Award winner Gene Hackman who
played Lex Luthor and relative newcomer
Christopher Reeve who actually portrayed
the lead character in addition to an
appearance fee of 3.7 million dollars
Brando was also contractually obligated
to take home 12 percent of the film's
profits the former Godfather's take was
19 million dollars in 2020 that's about
75 million dollars and this doesn't even
count the expensive looking Krypton sets
that filmmakers had to build for
Brando's brief scenes
it's almost impossible to imagine the
magnitude of the production behind Ben
Hur the 1959 adaptation of Lou Wallace's
novel and remake of the 1925 silent film
of the same name is memorable for its
extravagance a stunning nine-minute
Chariot race is the Crux of Wallace's
story and William Wyler's feature
gravitates around the same centerpiece
enduring a claim is a deserving
accomplishment following five years of
preparation the production was tireless
and demanding including 300 sets
covering 140 Acres nine Sound stages and
thousands of extras
set at chinachita studios in Italy it
was the largest film set of its era the
arena alone set in the fictional ancient
city Antioch was built by a construction
team of 750 workers created to capture
the race between Judah Ben Hur and
Masala shot over 10 weeks the singular
scene cost 4 million dollars in today's
money that's over 34 million dollars or
around 3.7 million dollars for each
minute of footage Metro Goldwyn Mayer
wanted the experience to lure audiences
into theaters though and it worked to
this day Ben Hur is one of the highest
grossing films ever proving sometimes
that Hefty Investments pay off
in 2001 director Michael Bay at the time
best known for Armageddon took his
penchant for big explosions and dazzling
effects shots and applied them to a
story set against the backdrop of actual
historical events the result Pearl
Harbor an epic action movie that takes
place primarily during events leading up
to the 1941 Japanese military bombing of
the U.S base in Hawaii Bay went all out
to realistically and graphically depict
the bombing of Pearl Harbor one of the
most famous and destructive acts in
American history and this is no
computer-generated Mayhem in Bloodshed
Bay used practical effects and a lot of
them the crew employed the use of 700
sticks of dynamite and 4 000 gallons of
gasoline to properly blow up six
inactive ships from the Navy it took
around a month to set everything up and
the director certainly didn't want to
miss anything so he set up 12 cameras to
film it all in all this one scene in
Pearl Harbor cost approximately 5.5
million dollars
in 2018 the North American box office
has had its share of high-profile bombs
they were so low the worst performing
Star Wars movie in the history of Star
Wars and Skyscraper the millionth movie
Dwayne Johnson's made this year but
nothing even comes close to the
disastrous performance of the Chinese
film Azura made with a reported budget
of 113 million dollars Azura debuted to
just 7.1 million dollars and before the
weekend was over it had been pulled from
theaters so why did China's most
expensive movie ever made bomb so hard
at the box office
what is Azura
an adaptation of ancient Tibetan Legends
and Buddhist mythology Azura follows a
young man who's discovered he's destined
to save a Heavenly Dimension which is
under attack by a three-headed King
named Azura over the course of his
journey he discovers he's The
Reincarnation of one of Azura's heads
which had lost a hundred years ago
during a previous Invasion attempt Azura
is about a hero's journey one that was
pitched since the start of a trilogy but
it doesn't look like any sequels are
coming anytime soon
sabotage
Azura's producers are accusing China's
most prominent film review aggregating
websites of letting users tank the movie
ratings with illegitimate reviews there
are three sites in China that work as
the equivalent of rotten tomatoes and
Metacritic Asura's early average score
and one was an 8.4 out of 10. while the
other two registered at 4.9 and a 3.1
what explains that discrepancy the
people behind Azura are convinced that
their movie is the victim of a focused
malicious attack specifically The
Producers claim that they discovered a
large number of 1 out of 10 scores from
suspicious looking users which were
posted immediately after the film hit
theaters in an official statement they
have announced whoever is behind this is
dirty stupid and ridiculous
yanked from theaters
rather than cut their losses and ride
out the storm Azura's filmmakers decided
to snatch their movie back out of
theaters as quickly as possible only a
few other movies have gotten the hook in
China in 2012 Quentin Tarantino's Django
and chained was unexpectedly pulled from
Chinese Theaters literally minutes after
being released but that was only done
for the sake of censorship and Django
returned to theaters in a matter of
weeks after edits were made Azura's
situation is entirely different it was
pulled by the film's own producers for
the DraStic purposes of editing it to
somehow make it better but to
appreciably raise the movie's quality
through editing would likely take months
as opposed to weeks
world class FX
one of Azura's biggest attempted
Innovations is its larger than usual
focus on special effects this might seem
unusual to American moviegoers who are
used to seeing state-of-the-art special
effects as a matter of course but in the
past Chinese produced movies typically
haven't had as much money pumped into
them as a result their special effects
often looked embarrassingly cheap Azura
aimed to break that mold it seems no
expense was spared to bring the movie's
effects to the standards set by American
movies that included hiring in demand
award-winning Hollywood Talent including
Veterans of Deadpool Lord of the Rings
and Furious 7 but while the money seems
to have all ended up on screen it
doesn't appear to have been a good
investment
middling marketing
another one of Azura's problems is the
sort of thing that could strike any
movie anywhere a lack of effective
marketing despite six years worth of
development and build up when it came
time to actually sell Azura to potential
audiences it looks like the ball got
dropped at a critical moment at least
that's one claim that's been circulating
stemming from Chinese market analysts
according to a representative of Beijing
based Showbiz market research firm fan
Kink based on our tracking pre-release
Market heat for this movie was quite low
below average regardless of whether or
not that's an accurate assessment of the
situation Azura now has a reputation as
a movie almost nobody wanted to see
untested director what else could have
gone wrong here for one thing director
Peng Zhang has an untested quantity
though he's been a stunt coordinator for
many Hollywood Productions including
Wonder Woman The Last Samurai and the
rush hour 3. Azura is his first ever
project as director think about that for
a second what's purported to be the most
expensive film ever made in the history
of China was directed by a person who
had never directed a movie before in his
life we're not saying Azura's failure is
Sang's faults we're just pointing out
that a first-time director seems like an
incredibly strange choice to head up
such an expensive high-stakes production
it's no secret that Netflix is a big
spender in 2017 alone the streaming
service dropped 6.3 billion dollars on
original and acquired programming
demolishing the video content budgets of
Viacom Amazon CBS apple and Facebook but
the Lion's Share of Netflix's budget of
course goes to original programming and
to do that the company has signed off on
some seriously extravagant series but
which are the most expensive shows
Netflix has ever produced we've got your
numbers
Hemlock Grove American creature killer
series Hemlock Grove was supposed to be
a Surefire hit for Netflix but it ended
up being little more than an average
show with a hefty price tag is there
something you want to tell me I'm about
to do things I don't want to
sooner or later I'm gonna have to give
in when it premiered in 2013 Hemlock
Grove ranked among Netflix's most
expensive shows to date reportedly
costing 40 million dollars for season
1's 13 episodes far more than most major
television networks are willing to Shell
out for even a 22 episode run entire
Bloodlines are about to become extinct
the series received a less than Stellar
critical reception though it did manage
to Garner a dedicated fan base which
ultimately kept the show alive for two
additional Seasons before Netflix pulled
the plug
Orange is the New Black as one of
Netflix's most well-known and widely
acclaimed series it's not surprising
that Orange is the New Black ranks among
the most expensive offerings on the
platform is it complicated ladies and a
complicated Place according to Peter
Miceli former co-head of TV at CAA the
show runs just under 4 million dollars
per episode but investing in the screen
rights to Piper kerman's Memoir of the
same name has paid massive dividends for
Netflix in Awards and worldwide brand
recognition
house of cards at the time of its
creation political thriller House of
Cards set a new standard for Netflix for
Quality as well as production costs
former star and executive producer Kevin
Spacey once said the production
reportedly spent 100 million dollars on
the first season alone we don't
we make the terror as the show closes in
on its Sixth and final season San Spacey
in late 2018 the series will go down as
a hit for the platform Netflix
reportedly upped their subscriber count
by at least 27.5 million when House of
Cards debuted in 2013. with the ultra
popular political drama playing a major
role in the streaming service winning
their fans vote we're just getting
started
Seinfeld's comedy Netflix isn't just
shelling out for high-profile original
series it's also forking it over for
original stand-up as well and no deal
was more expensive than the one they
made with Jerry Seinfeld would I have
been funnier if I grew up in Peoria in a
whorehouse raised by prostitutes
absolutely but this is what I had to
work with Netflix reportedly paid
Seinfeld a staggering 100 million
dollars for a pair of stand-up specials
bundled with the streaming rights to his
hit web series Comedians and Cars
Getting Coffee but the platform was
happy to pay Seinfeld's lofty premium
Netflix's Chief content officer Ted
sarandos told deadline Jerry has known
the world over as both a great TV
innovator and beloved comic voice we are
incredibly proud to welcome him to the
Netflix comedy family you excited
excited but I'm looking forward to it
the get down
baz luhrmann and Stephen adley girges
South bronze musical drama the get down
caused a lot of tension between Sony
Pictures Television and Netflix
according to variety the show's two and
a half year production saw two show
Runners and a whole slew of riders come
and go allegedly due to lerman's
involvement a money-burning budget
coupled with a lack of actual filming
saw Sony get fed up quickly but
Netflix's surrandos refused to Green
Light development until Lerman agreed to
direct the series from start to finish
Roberto where I'm from ain't the slums
we got Kings and that's what I'll be my
friends and me when the get Downs 12
episode season finally wrapped
production reportedly ended up costing
at least 120 million dollars and
possibly more than 190 million dollars
all in making it one of the most
expensive shows in television history
but while it was canceled after its
first season Netflix's VP of original
content Cindy Holland told variety we're
about supporting our artists and
supporting their Vision working with baz
and his team was one of the most
rewarding experiences of my life
the crowd Netflix's historical drama the
crown tells the biographical story of
Queen Elizabeth II and boasts production
costs that would make the real royal
family tighten their corsets what do you
want a degree no one wants a college
lecturer Sovereign they want a queen the
Show's first season alone reportedly
caused a record-setting 130 million
dollars in 2016. although Show creator
Peter Morgan thinks that estimation is
closer to the total cost for the first
two seasons that still equates to a
whopping 6.5 to 13 million dollars per
hour long episode helping drive up
production costs was the Flawless
Recreation of Queen Elizabeth's wedding
dress which cost approximately thirty
seven thousand dollars we had teams of
six people working for six weeks just
embroidering the train and the dress
that and someone had to sign off on a
life-size replica of Buckingham Palace
altered carbon debuting in February 2018
dystopian cyberpunk series altered
carbon is rumored to be one of Netflix's
most expensive shows you've been
provided with this body
came equipped with military-grade
neurochem and combat muscle memory based
on the 2002 novel by Richard K Morgan
altered carbon remained in development
for nearly a decade and a half
originally optioned by Warner Brothers
the show began its expensive march to
Netflix's lineup once Terminator Genesis
screenwriter Lita calagritis and Game of
Thrones director Miguel sapochnik signed
on the exact cost of altered carbon's
production remains a conservatively
estimated 7 million dollars per episode
however calagritis told thr that number
is really funny I feel comfortable
saying that that number is not correct I
would say it's inaccurate regardless of
how off the first season 70 million
dollar estimate may be if this show gets
its second season it'll likely be
breaking the bank as one of Netflix's
most expensive shows ever I thought
you'd be bigger they made me bring all
this backup
[Music]
everyone expects some props to be
destroyed during a film shoot every once
in a while though something breaks that
no one expected or budgeted for these
are the costliest things destroyed while
making movies historic toilets and all
when Jennifer Jason Lee watched in
horror as Kurt Russell smashes a replica
of an authentic 1870s Martin guitar in
the hateful eight her reaction was
entirely real because Russell
unknowingly destroyed the actual Martin
and not the replica
whoa
someone forgot to swap the real guitar
for the prop Lee told billboard Kurt
felt terrible he had no idea when he
found out his eyes literally welled up
Lee was heartbroken she'd just learned
to play guitar on that Martin and she'd
even been allowed to take it home to
practice before she learned it was a
museum piece Lee had even inquired about
the price she was interested in taking
it home once production was done Martin
guitar Museum director dick Oak told
Reverb that the museum quote will no
longer loan guitarist movies under any
circumstances
Skyfall the third James Bond movie to be
filmed in ishtan Bull might be the last
film there after a stuntman crashed
motorcycle into a 330 year old jewelry
shop the opening Chase sees Bond
pursuing the villainous Patrice across
the rooftops of Istanbul it culminates
in a dramatic crash through a breakable
prop window into the tight vibrant
corridors of the Grand Bazaar what you
don't see is the immediate aftermath
swerving to avoid packed throngs of
extras the stuntmen lost control of his
bike and smashed right through the real
crystal glass window of a historic
jewelry shop it's incredible how much
preparation went into this scene and how
things went awry anyway production
manager Menders Demir described the
process to the guide Istanbul before
shooting we had to negotiate and
convince 1 650 shop owners in the area
of the Grand Bazaar the spice bazaar and
in between the crew also had to secure
countless permits from turkey's Ministry
of culture Transportation Commission and
Istanbul's Police Department finally the
stunt was rehearsed several times to
ensure it would go off without a hitch
meet boybee the Shop's owner said
repairs were costly complicated and
resulted in Lost Revenue he explained
Reuters this place is regulated by the
Council of monuments we can't even
change our window without their
permission he also revealed the response
from skyfall's production no one from
the movie crew came to ask what are your
losses we filed a complaint at the
police station
in a thrilling scene in Christopher
Nolan's legendary 2008 movie The Dark
Knight The Joker and his gang divert and
trap a SWAT escort in a tight underpass
they managed to destroy several Vans and
even a police helicopter Batman enters
The Fray in his Batmobile having just
taken out a few parked cars himself it's
a chaotic exciting sequence captured
with close kinetic camera movements
unfortunately according to shortlist
those camera movements also resulted in
the destruction of an IMAX camera
breaking a camera during production
happens IMAX cameras are in another
League though the manufacturer typically
just rents out their cameras they're so
expensive most movie productions
wouldn't be able to afford them
otherwise how expensive are they a
single IMAX camera costs five hundred
thousand dollars according to premium
Beats that's right half a million
dollars or one camera
half a million is nothing to sneeze at
but given how profitable the movie was
that's a cost easily written off but
there was another Wrinkle in 2008 IMAX
cameras were very rare we're talking
count on one hand and half a finger left
over rare yep Nolan broke just one of
four IMAX cameras in the world at the
time
Christopher Nolan doesn't have just one
destroyed IMAX camera to his name during
production on 2012's The Dark Knight
Rises another IMAX camera was destroyed
the movie center is around a conflict
between Batman and Bane a criminal
mastermind who imposes martial law on
Gotham City this culminates in a massive
fight on the steps of Gotham City Hall
Catwoman rides the bat pod motorcycle
out of the building down the steps and
directly into an IMAX camera the
motorcycle isn't moving particularly
fast but the stunt woman and the
cameraman didn't realize they were on a
collision course and the IMAX camera was
knocked right out of his hands another
five hundred thousand dollars down the
drain at least this time the number of
IMAX cameras in the world had finally
climbed at double digits
Andre tarkovsky's 1986 film The
Sacrifice Takes the Cake for accidental
destruction that film burned down a
whole house twice to be fair Burning
Down The House was intentional less
intentional was the camera jamming the
crew was filming from a distance his
Flames ripped viciously through the
house people hustled about shouting
orders before it became abundantly clear
what happened tarkovsky was filmed
covering his face with both hands and
moaning as the house burned uselessly
tarkovsky said the last thing I expected
was for the camera crew to screw up the
house was rebuilt albeit a great expense
and the scene refilmed the movie went on
to be a classic but it's unlikely anyone
forgot the moment The Awful Truth of the
first House's destruction was revealed
Joaquin Phoenix has never been afraid to
go well beyond what's written in the
script sometimes that results in an
injury to himself as in Joker where the
actors so embodied his role he
dislocated his knee while filming a
scene as reported by comicbook.com in
the master Phoenix's character Freddie
quell is thrown into a jail cell
adjacent to Philip Z more Hoffman's
Lancaster dot sending quell into a rage
hands cuffed behind his back Phoenix
thrashes wildly in his cell he violently
throws himself repeatedly into the top
bunk bed kicks at the door and finally
stops the toilet the first stop
dislodges it but the second sends it
into the ground where it shatters
instantly director Paul Thomas Anderson
told Indie wire that unfortunately was a
real porcelain toilet a historic toilet
we could only do it once Phoenix told
the New York Times he drew inspiration
from wild animals in captivity that
react so viscerally that they often end
up hurting themselves he said I didn't
intend to break the thing I didn't know
that was possible
in an episode from the third season of
Battlestar Galactica Edward James Olmos
broke a model ship in an emotionally
charged fit of improvisation
Unfortunately they forgot to tell almost
that the model ship wasn't a prop but
instead was an original borrowed from a
museum almost told the crowd at the 2012
Planet Comic-Con I said what did you put
it in the scene for I mean God Almighty
I've just been told that my daughter's
dead what are you nuts that original he
reduced to kindling it was reportedly
worth a cool two hundred thousand
dollars
movies are a big money industry with
Millions invested over months or even
years of production the slightest
alteration can often have a ripple
effect that causes a film's budget to
quickly Skyrocket here's a look at
movies that lost tons of money from last
minute changes director Ridley Scott
decided to completely wipe Kevin Spacey
from his film all the money in the world
after the movie was already wrapped
following extensive accusations of
sexual misconduct against spacing the
cost was pre-estimated at around 10
million dollars which was a quarter of
the film's original 40 million dollar
budget within 36 hours of making the
call to pull Spacey Christopher Plummer
was announced as his replacement and 200
new shots were filmed in only nine days
reshoot costs aside there were
additional marketing expenses including
the early push for Spacey's Oscar
nomination that was canned the film was
pulled from the AFI Fest which likely
cost Sony six or seven figures
fortunately plumber more than picked up
the slack becoming the oldest actor to
be nominated for an Oscar the first Toy
Story was a touching animated movie that
helped make Pixar A filmmaking
Juggernaut Disney and Pixar originally
planned to release Toy Story 2 as a
60-minute direct video release much like
the studio had done with sequels to
Aladdin Cinderella The Lion King Mulan
and even Hunchback of Notre Dame Disney
simply didn't do big screen sequels yet
at a screening with Disney Executives
they decided it was simply too good for
the Home Video Market they opted to
change gears and release it in theaters
as a 90-minute feature with such news
you'd think the production crew would be
ecstatic however Pixar's John Lasseter
wasn't quite so happy he took over the
project and rewrote the entire plot in
two days with an estimated budget of 90
million dollars for the entire movie one
can assume that about half that amount
was used in the nine month long fire
drill that took place after the previous
year-long production work on character
creation and key environments was
already done but there are also several
notable additions including the
character director of Jesse who is added
in the rewrite decades ago when the
internet was in its infancy a draft of
the Scream 2 script was uploaded to the
web during the film's production this
sent director Wes Craven the production
team and Miramax into a panic fearing a
spoiled ending would ruin the movie they
quickly decided to rewrite and reshoot a
lot of the film it set production back
by months with added measures to prevent
the new script from being copied three
different endings were filmed to throw
everyone off and as a result audiences
got both a leaked and a surprise ending
to this decent horror classic rewrites
reshoots and an extra ending certainly
contributed a significant chunk to its
24 million dollar production budget
Superman and Superman 2 were filmed
simultaneously to cut down on production
time but as costs mounted Superman 2 was
stopped so producers could focus on the
first one after Superman proved to be a
success production started again on the
sequel well sort of there were a few
difficulties including Marlon Brando
wanting more money and Richard Lester
replacing the film's original director
Richard Donner Lester quickly scrapped
some footage and essentially started
over making the movie his own with a
final budget of around 54 million
dollars most of that was certainly spent
on reshoots it created massive
production expenses but it resulted in
two profitable films that critics
actually enjoyed Blade Runner is
considered a sci-fi classic that's
beloved by millions of course nothing
that great is easy to make after a few
test screenings failed to impress
audiences several last minute changes
were made including the infamous
Harrison Ford voiceover they don't
advertise for killers in a newspaper
that was my profession
the voiceover was so quick Ford
apparently never got to read it in
advance it was recorded eight times and
he was fairly unhappy about doing it
there were also plot changes and the
ending was tweaked to make it less
mysterious and more positive at 28
million dollars the film was at least
seven million dollars over budget while
adding a voiceover to an entire movie
might not seem like a Monumental cost
the total added expense left Blade
Runner just shy of recouping its money
in theaters fortunately for sci-fi fans
and the many filmmakers who've since
been influenced by the movie cult status
awaited on the Home Video Market 35
years after it faded from theaters it
got a sequel almost as widely acclaimed
as the original
one of the saddest stories surrounding a
last-minute movie change involves former
Saturday Night Live star Chris Farley
who was the original voice of Shrek at
the time of his death Farley had
recorded 80 to 90 percent of his lines
fellow SNL Alum Mike Myers was quickly
cast to replace him at Myers request
script changes were made to better
accommodate his brand of humor Meyers
realized that his initial take on the
big green guy wasn't quite right so he
wanted to re-record his lines with a
Scottish accent at that point more than
a third of the movie had been animated
meaning mouth movements facial
expressions and whatever else was in the
scene would need to be redone the cost
was estimated at 4 million to 5 million
dollars which was about 10 of the film's
final budget but it paid off in the end
before Marvel started its own Film
Studio along with the massively
successful Marvel Cinematic Universe
other Studios attempted to turn the
Publisher's characters into Blockbuster
franchises the results were often less
than spectacular case in point 2003's
Daredevils starring Ben Affleck is Matt
Murdock blind lawyer by day secretly
super powered vigilante by night it was
never meant to be a big budget superhero
movie but the success of Sam raimi's
Spider-Man gave the studio other ideas
what started as a dark look at the
repercussions of violence was toned down
for broader appeal with the contractual
obligation to make the movie PG-13
director Mark Steven Johnson had to
re-edit Daredevil twice test audiences
apparently wanted more romance between
Daredevil and Elektra so more Quick Cuts
were made and again because of the
success of the effects spectacle that
was Spider-Man the studio wanted more
visual Thrills nearly 30 minutes were
chopped including a subplot involving
Coolio all of the special effects and
edits drove the budget from 50 million
to 80 million dollars regardless it all
worked out in the end as Daredevil not
only made enough money to spawn the
Electra spin-off but it also LED
something more for Affleck and Electra
actress Jennifer Garner who were married
in 2005. in Enemy Mine Louis Gossett Jr
plays an Alien named drak and Dennis
Quaid is Earth pilot Willis Savage
they're stranded together on a distant
planet after a battle with wait for it
each other naturally they band together
to weather the elements and defeat a
common enemy the studio was unhappy with
early shots from director Richard Long
Crane and decided to Halt production
after a large portion of shooting was
completed execs still loved the concepts
actors and stories so director Wolfgang
Peterson was brought in to finish the
job or really restart the job and then
finish it because the footage sets and
makeup weren't up to Snuff after the
studio mandated overhaul enemy mine's
original 17 million dollar budget
ballooned to over 40 million dollars it
never recouped its costs earning only 12
million dollars but it did eventually
earn bragging rights as a cult classic
Guillermo del Toro's vision for mimic
which involved humans possessed by a
mutant tree Beetle ended up falling flat
with Studio execs instead they
envisioned giant killer Cocker
approaches add that fundamental
disagreement to the list of other things
the studio didn't appreciate and the
result is what Del Toro calls his
imperfect child the experience was so
bad he almost quit making movies
altogether a second unit was reportedly
enlisted in case the studio decided to
replace him with an estimated budget of
30 million dollars it was generally
penned by critics and only made 25
million dollars back Del Toro later got
to return to make a director's cut
eliminating second unit shots and
reinstating more atmosphere he
eventually went on to direct Classics
like Hellboy Pan's Labyrinth and the
shape of water
with a production budget of 300 million
dollars a slew of iconic superheroes in
one movie and a ton of Talent on and off
the screen Justice League just had to
succeed right well not exactly and that
Hefty price tag didn't really help
either part of the cost resulted from a
director swap that became necessary
after Zack Snyder stepped down to deal
with the family tragedy writer director
Joss Whedon came in and reshot 15 to 20
percent of the movie costing at least 25
million dollars having to reshoot scenes
is expensive enough but bringing a cast
back in from other projects can lead to
even more problems such as the Henry
Cavill hairy upper lip debacle the actor
reprising his role as Superman had since
grown a mustache for Mission Impossible
Fallout as a result Warner Brothers was
forced to digitally remove cavil's
mustache adding to the already inflated
budget all that extra time and money
didn't help Justice League with critics
and though the movie still made hundreds
of millions of dollars at the box office
The Fallout inspired Warner Brothers to
re-examine its approach and retool its
plan for the DC extended Universe you
can call this one a mixed blessing
big budgets used to be exclusive to
Major Hollywood films but that was
before the current golden age of
Television started in the late 1990s TV
has never been this good or this pricey
here are some of the most expensive
scenes ever shot for the small screen
at 217 million dollars the Pacific was
the most expensive mini-series ever made
when it was released in 2010. its
depiction of the pelelu Beach Landings
in World War II alone cost five million
dollars a figure that becomes even more
staggering when you read the Hollywood
reporter's invoice breakdown some 300
actors worked on the four-day shoot the
lead's daily rate was 700 stunt extras
150 and regular extras 70 this was
economical according to the producers
who avoided big stars to offset the
Show's real money burners which included
uniforms visual effects and a whole
arsenal of guns explosives and tanks
then there was a CGI even simple effects
such as adding a muzzle flash to a
gunshot costs about 700 more complicated
adjustments such as removing or masking
features in the image run about forty
thousand dollars per shot three and a
half seconds of a landing craft for
example cost almost thirty thousand
dollars and things are just supposed
production expenses each standard 10
drawing principal photography cost
thirteen thousand five hundred dollars
the wide shots of which there were four
per day could add up to seventy thousand
dollars
spectacle costs money that's why the
pilots episode for last which famously
depicts a plane crash cost ABC between
10 million and 14 million dollars the
most expensive pilot in history at the
time the scene was constructed in
multiple locations it began to board a
mocked up plane interior in a California
Sound Stage where director J.J Abrams
used a skillful blend of practical
Ingenuity and CGI to capture the
horrifying Panic as the aircraft drops
out of the sky the CGI takes over as we
see the plane break apart and Scatter
across the ocean some additional
disturbing moments were filmed on the
coast of Oahu Hawaii it was here that
the most expensive prop was used a
decommissioned airliner the passenger
plane was bought in the Mojave Desert
and then transports it to Hawaii where
it was staged in catastrophic fashion
fortunately ABC's investment would reap
major dividends loss became one of the
biggest shows of the 2000s and
occasionally one of its most confusing
all right dude we're from the future
Game of Thrones is a big show a very big
show everything about it is massive
including the budget Metro reports that
the notorious 8th season costs 90
million dollars which means 15 million
dollars for each of the seasons six
episodes of these it's likely that the
Battle of Winterfell costs the most all
of the pricey ingredients are here as
we've been cast with established Fame
and Hefty salaries scores of extras
decked in unique costumes towering set
design and seamless integration of CGI
however this huge battle spits opinion
among viewers many bemoans how dimly lit
the cinematography was complaining that
they had to adjust the brightness on
their TVs because it was simply too dark
to watch I can't see that's your problem
not mine other viewers loved it with a
headline at Games Radar quoting a claim
that it was the most intense episode in
television history
the 18 million dollar pilot of Boardwalk
Empire is effectively one big piece of
World building that displays the show's
Glitz and glamor including the lavish
Boardwalk set that cost 5 million
dollars that's a lot it's quite a lot
the boardwalk set was staged in Green
Point Brooklyn and took months to build
in an interview with the Chicago Tribune
set designer Bob Shaw said that it was
the biggest outdoor set built in New
York City in almost 100 years then there
were the small details the storefronts
were based closely on the Atlantic City
Boardwalk Circa 1920. that's just one
part of the exhaustive research that
went into the project which covered
everything from Key moments of World War
One and prohibition to The Wider popular
culture of the era
tend to bulge when Warfare and
especially fire-breathing dragons are
involved
the crown has neither of those things
but 70 years of real history doesn't
come cheap in fact the crown is one of
the most expensive shows ever made with
the first season costing 130 million
dollars the price he has seen in the 10
episode run is Queen Elizabeth II's
wedding it features a replica dress that
according to Harper's Bazaar costs 37
000 to make this standout piece of
wardrobe was just one part of the show's
ornate Grandeur in a conversation on the
red carpet actor Claire Foy said every
single penny was spent on screen all the
locations are appropriate but
extraordinary the costumes were handmade
and designed also we were shooting in
London it's so rare that you're able to
shoot in London we shut down the mall
for an entire morning Matt Smith who
played Prince Philip added we had great
costumes great locations so I think all
the money went on screen
sense8 was always going to be an
expensive show because its eight main
characters are from every corner of the
Earth according to wired this globe
trotting Extravaganza was costing
Netflix nine million dollars per episode
when it was canceled in June 2017. of
the show's 24 episodes season 2's
Christmas special was likely the most
expensive in particular an underwater
scene that took the cast and crew all
the way to Malta filming underwater is
far more complex than filming on dry
land and it often requires up to three
times as many crew members then there
are creative concerns namely the
complications affecting light and color
which means waiting for the opportune
time period on the open sea or using
elaborate lighting equipment if working
in a tank either way it's a matter of
crew time and Technology all of which
costs plenty of money
Ryan is one of Amazon's proudest
exhibits it's announced the company's
intention to spend big money on big
drama 8 million dollars per episode to
be exact every action seen as an
explosive Testament to Amazon's Deep
Pockets pinpointing a certain scene
isn't easy because there are so many to
choose from but the subway shoots out in
season 1 episode 8 is definitely a
highlight as with so much of
Contemporary TV the lines between
reality and CG are blurred as Jack Ryan
edges down the subway tunnel gun in hand
after a brief shootout a train barrels
along the tracks obliterating one of the
men Ryan's just shut and it's exactly
that type of CGI driven moment that can
take a big bite out of an episode's
budget and it was totally worth it
most fans like to see their protagonists
kick ass especially when they're dealing
with zombies depicting this is usually a
rather modest Affair at least in the
scheme of Mega budget TV but which
Walking Dead scene took the biggest
chunk out of the show's budget well
season Seven's ninth episode saw prices
go up with a featured two old cars a
line of wire and a whole lot of Walkers
the bulk of the cast was likely incurred
during post-production processing all of
those CGI flying limbs does not come
cheap even the Walkers moans and groans
were added by Audio Specialists the
undead extras are asked to remain silent
as usual this scene was an amplification
of a budget that was already full of
expensive details for example Yahoo
reports that AMC paid the families of
Senoia Georgia while the majority of the
series has filmed 400 a month to
compensate for the household of
production and to discourage locals from
sharing any spoilers they might have
seen
[Music]
when friends started in 1994 the budget
was so tight that producers had to use
the bottled episode format which
required the crew to use as few sets as
possible and not even think of having
special guests well as everyone on the
face of the Earth knows friends will
become one of the biggest shows in the
history of American television earning
Warner Brothers a yearly syndication
revenue of 1 billion this success saw
the modestly staged show end up costing
a pretty penny for NBC by the eighth
season each main cast member was earning
750 000 for every 30 minutes episode
that's 25 000 a minute say when Brad
Pitt turned up for Thanksgiving dinner
it couldn't have been cheap still it's a
no-brainer when the choices between
money and an Unforgettable episode
friends or money
just like with loss back in 2004
showrunner JJ Abrams wanted friends to
make a strong first impression
unfortunately for Fox Executives a
sequence that included scores of extras
face melting special effects and a
custom-built set would contribute to a
10 million dollar budget the cost
breakdown would have shared much in
common with last a mugged up plane
interior a sound stage and detailed CGI
only this time there was a strong
serving of gory makeup applied to about
a dozen extras aboard the doomed plane
Fringe like other entries on this list
would see the budget fall after its
pilot plateauing at a rate of 4 million
dollars per episode
yet another case of pilot extravagance
the costumes period sets and star power
of vinyl is said to have cost 30 million
dollars however despite the
collaboration of Mick Jagger and
Martin's coursesi vinyl landed with
neither critics nor audiences so why did
it cost so much money well much like 70s
rock too much is never enough that's
what I'm talking about the pilots
episode was effectively one big scene
crammed with everything the viewers
could expect from the rest of the season
in the case of vinyl this manifested in
a large ensemble cast a sweeping
wardrobe of authentic 70s Garb and a
catalog of licensed music the Pilot's 30
million dollar price tag was just 33
percent of the first season's 100
million dollar budget which would
ultimately sink the show before it could
take off
The Big Bang Theory have become a
massive show by its 11th season it's 250
plus episodes brimmed with the
affectionate geekiness that fans around
the world identified with so for The
Season's final episode which featured
the marriage of Amy and Sheldon the show
needed an extra special guest the guest
of course was Mark Hamill the iconic
Star Wars actor
Hamill was the perfect choice to
officiate the wedding of two super Geeks
and he also brought some extra star
power to the show although this wedding
episode already boasted a bevy of
high-profile cameos including Kathy
Bates Jerry O'Connell Laurie Metcalfe
Will Wheaton plus many more and that's
basically how a simple sitcom can cost
nine million dollars for a single
episode
Rome is another lavish production that
was overwhelmed by its budget in many
ways Rome set the stage for Game of
Thrones which would reach a far bigger
audience using a similar Brew of power
politics and violence the budgetary peak
for Rome came with the depiction of the
Battle of Philippi which occurred in 42
BC during the Liberator Civil War it's a
huge scene that mixes dozens of extras
clad in full suits of armor and carrying
a variety of weapons also everything we
see is supplemented by CGI that
multiplies the scene's scope many times
over TV had never been staged like this
before a tarrowing blend of sword and
sandal Grandeur mixed with modern grit
and violence
Game of Thrones is a show that's too big
to mention just once of all the chaos
and Majesty that we witness the dragon
attack in season 7's fourth episode is
perhaps the most awesome and the most
expensive the execution of this
remarkable sequence was detailed in a
short HBO documentary when Director of
Photography Rob McLaughlin learned about
the scene he had an understandable
response oh boy that is gonna be a lot
of work McLaughlin's team operated at
least four cameras sometimes seven or
eight they also use three different
tracking vehicles to capture the huge
Dothraki Chargers which were also filmed
on cameras hoisted on Industrial cranes
then there were the helicopter drones
which were supplied by a third party to
add further Dynamic shots to this
complex sequence the Zenith of the
episode occurs when the dragon focuses
his deadly attack on the loot train
which we see from several perspectives
the Practical effects team worked
tirelessly to create a seamless line of
explosions that would not only look
authentic but also push an already epic
depiction of a dragon in battle to the
next level
making a big Hollywood Blockbuster ain't
cheap but how expensive is too expensive
which popular superhero just couldn't
save the day or rather the opening
weekend keep watching to find out
Sony has been trying to turn
Ghostbusters into a franchise for three
decades with little success thanks in
part to inflated expectations the
original Ghostbusters made 295 million
dollars worldwide in 1984. about 789
million dollars worldwide in today's
dollars five years later Ghostbusters 2
made 215 million dollars worldwide over
480 million dollars worldwide today so
when Sony finally made a new
Ghostbusters after the series spent
nearly 30 years in development hell they
apparently figured the new version would
land in that 500 to 800 million dollar
range that may explain why they spent a
bloated 144 million dollars on 2016's
Ghostbusters answer the call the big
problem is that it wasn't a sequel
featuring characters we knew and loved
but a reboot with a whole new cast that
typically doesn't work out and answer
the call was no exception the film
finished with 229 million dollars
worldwide not bad for a comedy in modern
Hollywood but not nearly enough to
Warrant a sequel instead Sony apparently
learned their financial lessons and made
2021's Ghostbusters afterlife for only
half the budget of answer the call
allowing it to turn a profit you are a
genius Patty I'm a Ghostbuster
battleship is considered one of the
biggest box office bombs of the past
decade and not even Rihanna's Legion of
fans would argue with that but it's not
for the reason you might think
Battleship wasn't a bomb because it
didn't make money it bombed because it
didn't make enough money Battleship
scored 313 million dollars worldwide in
2012. not bad for an insanely bad sci-fi
film based on a board game that was
mostly due to its 248 million dollar
International gross but it had The
Misfortune of debuting just after
Marvel's The Avengers which went on to
become one of the highest grossing films
of all time the crazy part Battleship
and the Avengers had almost the same
budget The Avengers cost 225 million
dollars about only 5 million dollars
more than battleships 220 million
dollars yep Universal almost spent the
same amount on friggin Battleship as
Marvel did on the Avengers according to
the New Yorker Battleship was green lit
with a 150 million dollar budget which
would have allowed it to turn a profit
but after the production ran into issues
the studio had to throw tens of millions
of dollars down the drain to try and fix
it
just because a character is a household
name doesn't mean he's a box office draw
thus while Superman is probably the most
famous superhero of all time he's no
longer the most bankable at the box
office though he was once in 1978
Superman the movie made moviegoers
believe a man could fly and made a lot
of money doing it earning 300 million
dollars worldwide about 1.2 billion
today Mighty impressive for the Man of
Steel after the original franchise ended
with a whimper with 1987 Superman 4 the
Quest for Peace Warner Brothers spent
almost two decades trying to figure out
what to do next the rest was 2006's
Superman Returns which at 232 million
dollars cost a lot more than other
superhero origin stories at the time
2002's Spider-Man for instance only cost
139 million dollars to make while 2005's
Batman Begins cost 150 million dollars
Superman Returns ended up earning 391
million dollars worldwide with
Spider-Man or Batman Begins but budget
it would have made money and likely
would have spawned a whole new Trilogy
just as those two films did thanks to
its inflated budget though it has been
considered a failure and signaled the
final end of the classic Superman
franchise by 2012 the Pirates of the
Caribbean franchise had earned about 3.5
billion dollars across four films pride
comes before the fall so Disney Johnny
Depp director Gore verbinski and
producer Jerry Bruckheimer thought their
relationship was a license to print gold
and could do no wrong but the Lone
Ranger went wrong very very wrong
beginning with the whole idea of
Reviving an outdated radio Western that
hadn't been popular for decades in
Disney's defense they realized the
film's budget was getting out of control
and even shut down production to contain
it it didn't work sources vary with the
final budget estimated to have been
between 225 million dollars and 250
million dollars wherever it landed The
Lone Ranger would have had to break
records to break even for context The
Lone Ranger cost about 100 million
dollars more than the first Pirates of
the Caribbean film despite starring
Armie Hammer who has since been accused
of cannibalism and worse the film still
made 260 million dollars worldwide so
with a smaller budget it could have been
a success but with those costs making a
Lone Ranger 2 would have been a true
train wreck
thanks to Star Wars Marvel Pixar and
Disney plus it may seem like the house
that Walt built is indestructible this
conveniently ignores the fact that
Disney's original live action output has
mostly been a wasteland of box office
bombs including some of the biggest
disappointments of all time in fact
Disney's desperation for live-action
movies is probably why they purchased
Marvel and lucasfilms in the first place
one Disney film that did so-so and would
have been a big hit if not for the even
bigger budget was TRON Legacy Tron
bombed in 1982 and while it built a cult
following making a legacy sequel 28
years later to a movie Nobody saw in
theaters was a bit of a head scratcher
couple that with the 200 million dollar
price tag and you'd have to wonder
whether Mickey lost his marbles smartly
though Disney positioned Tron legacy as
the must-see holiday Blockbuster of 2010
and it mostly worked as the film earned
399 million dollars worldwide at Disney
spent just a little bit less there's no
question we would have seen more sequels
as it is though the legacy of Tron is a
failure
speaking of waiting three decades to
make an overpriced sequel of a movie
that was a flop to begin with say hello
to 2017's Blade Runner 2049 the original
Blade Runner made 39 million dollars on
a 28 million dollar budget back in 1982
meaning it wasn't a disaster but was far
from a hit still it has been hailed as a
masterpiece by critics so surely that
would translate into ticket sales 35
years later right Warner Brothers bet
185 million dollars that it would it
didn't with 258 million dollars
worldwide the sequel far exceeded the
originals take but didn't come close to
becoming a hit we can argue all day
whether Deckard was a replicant but
there's no debate on this Blade Runner
should not have been replicated at 185
million dollars
what do you do when your movies in
production isn't working and you've
already spent a ton of money on it
option A is finishing the film and
hoping for the best option b is dropping
another several million in the hopes of
fixing it Warner Brothers opted for
option b with Justice League and the
result was a mixed bag at the box office
after spending 275 million dollars on
2017's Justice League Warner Brothers
removed director Zack Snyder replaced
him with problematic Avengers director
Joss Whedon and dumped another 25
million dollars into reshoots loading
the budget to an incredible 300 million
dollars they still hoped to turn a
profit as Batman vs Superman had made
872 million dollars worldwide and
Justice League was adding Wonder Woman
Flash and Aquaman to the film it should
have been a Surefire recipe for Success
instead fans and critics alike hated the
film bad word of mouth tanked it at the
box office and it limped to a 655
million dollar worldwide gross though it
made a small profit it destroyed the
franchise and earned less than half of
what Marvel's The Avengers had brought
in five years earlier All In All Justice
League was more train wreck than
tentpole what was it like
coming back
itchy
conventional wisdom says the mummy
franchise was going strong until the
mummy Tomb of the Dragon Emperor bombed
as with most things the conventional
wisdom isn't wrong it's just missing
part of the story yes Tomb of the Dragon
Emperor was also really really bad even
for a franchise that never got much love
from critics however the mummy franchise
made money with every movie The problem
is that the budget on Tomb of the Dragon
Emperor was so much bigger than its
predecessors 1999's The Mummy cost 80
million dollars to make while 2001's The
Mummy Returns cost 98 million dollars
but when Tomb of the Dragon Emperor came
out in 2008 it cost a whopping 175
million dollars Tomb of the Dragon
Emperor actually earned 405 million
dollars worldwide almost the same amount
as each of the previous films but with a
budget twice as high it didn't make
nearly as much money killing the
franchise deader than imotep
Harrison Ford is one of the 10 highest
grossing movie stars of all time with
career earnings 10 billion dollars
worldwide and that's unadjusted for
inflation however outside of Indiana
Jones and the kingdom of the Crystal
Skull and Star Wars the Force awakens
Ford hasn't had an above the title hit
since 2000's What Lies Beneath that
should have changed in 2020 with the
Call of the Wild keyword should The Call
of the Wild made 62 million dollars
domestically and 107 million dollars
worldwide fairly modest amounts but for
a film about a guy and his dog it did
quite well one massive problem though
20th Century Fox spent an incredible 125
million dollars to make it blame budget
itis a term for Hollywood's inexplicable
inability to make mid-budget movies the
big issue was their decision to use CGI
to create Buck the Dog which turned what
could have been a modest hit into a 50
million dollar loser
some box office observers argue that
Robert Downey Jr isn't a movie star
outside his signature Tony Stark role
while there's no denying most of his
15.7 billion dollar worldwide career
earnings come from playing The Man in
the Iron suit he has proven to be a
reliable draw in films like Tropic
Thunder and the Sherlock Holmes movies
no his butts in seats Bank ability isn't
on par with Leonardo DiCaprio or Dwayne
The Rock Johnson but no other movie
stars have that drawing power either it
seemed like Downey Jr would add to his
bankable resume with 2020's Doolittle
but instead that movie turned out to be
a Titanic turkey and not a talking one
either yet Doolittle actually made 251
million dollars worldwide about on par
with other live-action kids movies
released in the past 15 years as the
sub-genre has been dominated for more
than a decade by animation the problem
somebody at Universal thought it was a
good idea to spend 175 million dollars
on Doolittle which is actually more than
Iron Man 2 cost to make expecting Downey
Jr to pull MCU numbers in a non-ir man
role was dumb still he might have been
one of the only humans popular enough to
save Doolittle from utter destruction
that's not good as far as I'm concerned
I'm the only human here comedies Hit or
Miss at the box office as humor doesn't
always translate overseas what's a movie
studio to do you don't spend Millions on
pricey VFX like you're making a Marvel
movie instead you spend most of its
money on the movie star and hope he can
put butts in the seats unless you're
Universal that is Bruce Almighty with
Jim Carrey's mug plastered on the poster
made 484 million dollars on an 81
million dollar budget in 2003 making it
not only Carrie's biggest hit but one of
the highest grossing comedies ever but
Bruce Almighty worked because of the Jim
Carrey as God concept not the brand
there was no indication audiences would
show up to Steve Carell as Noah just
because Universal slapped Almighty on it
welp Universal felt otherwise and spent
175 million dollars on the film more
than twice Bruce's budget making it the
most expensive comedy ever made to that
point the budget was supposed to be just
100 140 million dollars but costs ran up
thanks to CGI and live animals
ultimately the film made 174 million
dollars worldwide which wasn't bad for a
comedy sequel that didn't even star the
original actor but was a disaster of
biblical proportions based on the budget
[Music]